Brian, tell the judges
about your weapon.
I really like
how it turned out.
I was able to put a few
of my own personal touches
on the handle.
The five stars represent the
smiths in the competition.
Matt, tell us
about your blade.
I had a rough time this week.
I broke it on day three
in my own testing,
but I had 14 hours left.
I made a blade I'm pretty proud
of out of some [inaudible]
spring.
All right, gentlemen.
This is my favorite part
of this competition.
Up first, the kill test.
Doug?
[music playing]
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do,
we'll take your sword
and deliver hacks and
slashes on this big carcass.
Brian, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Absolutely.
I really like how
the blade turned out,
but I'm super nervous.
Depending on where you
hit that blade, you know,
it can always snap apart.
[music playing]
Phew.
All right.
Brian, let's talk
about your blade.
First up, your edge
is razor sharp.
It lacerated easily through
bones, through the spine.
The one issue here is that
you have a very blocky handle.
Aside from that, it will kill.
Good job.
Thanks.
Matt, ready to chop?
I've been ready.
Let's do this.
MATT: I'm really nervous.
But as long as this blade
doesn't wrap around in a circle
and hug this pig,
I'm in good shape.
[music playing]
OK, Matt.
Its balance and weight is
very forward for a chopper.
But your edge is sharp enough
to lacerate into the carcass.
It did chop the spine.
It did chop bone.
This will kill.
- Thank you.
Gentlemen, this
is a strength test.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge,
I'm going to chop into
these huge logs 10 times.
Remember, this test is all about
what happens to your weapons,
and not what
happens to the logs.
Brian, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I think so, yeah.
All right.
[music playing]
Well, Brian, your
edge held up perfectly.
There's no bending, no
warping, just still razor sharp
all the way down.
Man, it was fun to swing.
Well done.
Thank you.
Matt, you're up.
Are you ready?
Give it a try.
I'm a little anxious that
it's going to kink or bend.
Don't chip, don't break,
don't chip, don't break.
[music playing]
Ah.
Well, Matt, there's
so much forward weight
that it actually bent that way.
On the plus side, your
edge held up beautifully.
I mean, there's no problems
with that edge at all.
It's still very sharp.
But this [inaudible] in
it, it's significant.
[music playing]
Bladesmiths, you both brought
in some pretty extraordinary,
historic weapons.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Brian, congratulations.
You are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Thank you.
Matt, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Matt, your blade
is impressive.
We saw that it could kill.
But unfortunately,
in the strength test,
it took a significant bend,
and it's for that reason
we have to let you go.
I understand.
Matt, please
surrender your golok.
Even with losing,
at the end of the day,
I don't feel like I really
lost because I went way
further than I ever expected.
I don't know enough
about it yet that I
can make that perfect blade.
So you know, I'll keep learning.